the Battle of Winterfell is almost upon
us and it seems as if almost all of
Westeros is about to converge in an epic
battle over light and night and we need
a hero someone to claim the mantle as
Slayer of the night king destroyer of
the Horde of darkness in these times we
look to our greatest hope of survival
our most stalwart champion one who has
proven to be our only hope in times of
great need Jaime Lannister whoa whoa
whoa did you say that right surely you
mean Jon Snow aka Aegon Targaryen the
friggin prince that was promised nope
okay well obviously you're not looking
at Danny mother of dragons badass Queen
and did I mention mother of friggin
dragons nope
I'm talking about old no han Jaime
Lannister and let me tell you why
there's a theory that's been circulated
around which has been churning in my
head for some time now and the more I
think about it the more I'm falling for
it I think I'm falling for you in the
ultimate endgame here is that Jaime will
be born again as oz or ah hai not Jon
Snow and not Daenerys who are both the
more obvious choices for azor Ahai if
Game of Thrones were a more traditional
narrative but it seems to me like Jon
being as our hai is a little on the nose
for this show and after all it wouldn't
be the first time Mila saundra got the
details of a prophecy wrong because of
mistakes I made Stannis Allah tyrion
brings some words of wisdom as well
prophecy is like a half trained mule it
looks as though it might be useful but
the moment you trust in it it kicks you
in the head so like a half trained mule
let's take a look at the prophecy of
azor Ahai and specifically two main
aspects of it the first is the legend of
light bringer which tells the story of a
hero who labored over many days and
through many trials in order to craft
the sword Lightbringer the red sword of
heroes and drive back the darkness the
beginning of the legend goes like this
darkness lay over the world and a hero
azor Ahai was chosen to fight against it
to fight the darkness azor Ahai needed
to forge a hero's sword he labored for
30 days and 39
scintilla was done however when he went
to temperate in water this sword broke
he was not one to give up easily
so he started over the first thing to
get out of our minds is the idea that
light bringer will be an actual sword
that needs forging and refocus ourselves
on the idea of light bringer as Jaime
himself when we were introduced to Jaime
he's widely known to be one of the most
proficient fighters in the land until
his hand is cut off when Jaime sword
hand is cut off he loses everything that
made him Jaime Lannister and begins the
process of being reborn something we can
take both as a transformation of
character and perhaps an allegory for
the beginning of a transformation into
as aura a high Jaime's prowess as a
swordsman his ego and swagger are all
gone in this moment but with it also the
hand that killed the Mad King and dubbed
him Kingslayer and Jaime literally
begins to temper himself in water during
the bath scene with Brienne and
Harrenhal here we learn that Jaime
actually had a just motive for breaking
his oath and killing the king homes
bendin in that beds killing the Mad King
saved thousands of men women and
children from burning alive and while we
begin to see one of the most incredible
transformations in Game of Thrones as
Jaime goes from villain to hero Jamie
begins to see himself change as well a
journey that starts here and will
eventually drive him to fight for good
shedding his old title of Kingslayer and
becoming just Jaime the next part of the
prophecy states the second time he took
50 days and 50 nights to make this sword
even better than the first to temper it
this time he captured a lion and drove
the sword into its heart but once more
the steel shattered the lion imagery
here is far too vibrant to ignore but
when did Jaime drive a sword into a
lion's heart
well when Tyrion kills their father
Tywin now it is true that Tyrion is the
one who committed the physical act but
Jamie's the one who sets the deed in
motion not only does Jaime free Tyrion
from the cells of the red
keep bleeding to Tyrians crossbow moment
he's also the one who provides Tyrion
with a motive revealing the truth about
Taisha Tyrians first love and take a
look at where the first crossbow lands
in Tywin right through his heart he
captured a line and drove the sword into
its heart in many ways Tywin's death
would never have happened without these
actions from Jaime even Cersei believes
this saying here you may be a monster
but at least you know and so begins the
shattering of Jaime's relationship with
Cersei pushing Jaime further down the
path of fighting for good
the prophecy continues the third time
with a heavy heart for he knew
beforehand what he must do to finish the
blade he worked for a hundred days and
nights until it was finished this time
he called for his wife Nissa Nissa and
asked her to bare her breasts he drove
his sword into her living heart her soul
combining with the steel of the sword
creating Lightbringer the red sword of
heroes although he had Lightbringer azor
Ahai did not fight alone many have
argued that Jamie as azor Ahai deviates
from Jaime's purpose on the show that
his story revolves too closely around
the Lannisters and Cersei and has not
enough to do with White Walkers and the
night king but I believe his purpose can
fit perfectly into both to finish the
prophecy Jaime must drive his sword into
his wife's living heart and wouldn't it
be perfect if that was Cersei many
believe Jaime's purpose for the rest of
the season is to kill his sister there's
ample evidence for this Cersei being
foretold and when your tears have
drowned you the valonqar shall wrap his
hands about your pale white throat and
choke the life from you
valonqar being high valerian for little
brother which technically Jaime is so
why not also believe that Cersei is also
Nissa Nissa in this scenario we know
that through the second part of the azor
Ahai prophecy and the events that
naturally have followed that Jaime and
Cersei are pulling farther and farther
apart and if we believe that
Lightbringer will actually be Jaime's
sword han returned to life it makes the
idea of him wrapping his hands around
her pale throat all the more believable
side note I'd also like to point out
that
back in the bathtub and harrenhal Jaime
mentions the reason he killed the Mad
King was because of his desire to burn
the city and wildfire something that
Cersei eventually does herself by
blowing up the great Sept of Baelor
interesting connection there now some
believe that with Circe's death Jaime
will also perish dialogue like this is
often spoken in the show and in the
books we will leave the world together
as we came into it and Jaime has said
how do you want to go some speculate
this could actually be Brienne but I
think this could still be Cersei Jaime
once he kills Nissa Nissa will be reborn
the old Jaime will be gone and he will
now be azor Ahai now as I mentioned
earlier there's another main aspect of
the azor Ahai prophecy to address and
it's what we've learned through Mila
Sandra and the scrolls from the ancient
books of us I this prophecy claims that
azor Ahai shall be born again amid smoke
and salt to wake dragons out of stone
this will occur after a long summer when
an evil cold darkness descends upon the
world and the red star bleeds it is said
that wielding light bringer once again
azor Ahai will stand against the others
and deliver the world from darkness many
see this prophecy is leaning heavily
toward the idea that Daenerys is azor
Ahai I mean who else has awoken dragons
out of stone but george RR martin
himself has said prophecy can be a
tricky business
master amon gives an interesting opinion
in chapter 35 of a feast for crows
believing the salt part of said prophecy
could be the salt from tears
perhaps the tears of Jaime Lannister
killing the love of his life these
prophecies are cryptic things many
believed the red comet seen in season 2
was this red star that bleeds but could
it not also be the red star bleeding
from the heads of the faith militant
that were killed
seeing the Sep blown up in wildfire
something Jaime tried to prevent from
happening with the Mad King could that
not be the bleeding red star that sets
Jaime away from Cersei and further
pushes him towards the path of azor Ahai
there are multiple subtle references to
flames and rebirth revolving around
Jaime especially with his sword hand
the snowflake melting on his cold golden
hand here while he departs for the north
in season seven in season 4 when Jojen
is asked by Meera and bran when will we
know the end he says a burning hand a
burning right hand the same sword hand
that is now made of gold on Jamie
Lannister and who else but Jamie could
bring about the end of the darkness with
a hand burning like the fires of azor
Ahai what would be more poetic than the
Kingslayer being redeemed to become the
night Kingslayer the last thing I want
to mention is the final very important
sentence of the Lightbringer prophecy
although he had Lightbringer azor Ahai
did not fight alone many believe that
Jon or den he must be a Zora hi because
this is primarily their story they are
the leads the ones who brought dragons
and the hearts and wills of men and
women together and to this final point
to fight the night King and the White
Walkers but you're missing this very
important part of the prophecy as Ora
hai does not do it by his or her self
azor Ahai did not fight alone once we
see that azor Ahai is not the story of
Game of Thrones but simply a tool that
will be utilized to overthrow the
darkness we can see that it doesn't have
to be John or Danny why not Jamie
then once his journey is complete let
John or Daenerys figure out who shall
sit on the throne there's nothing in the
prophecy that states azor Ahai has to be
that person and finally we have brands
conversation with Jamie from episode 2
of the new season Jamie apologizes to
bran and claims he's not that person
anymore
that man who threw a child out of a
window once again showing Jamie's
transformation curious as to why bran
didn't reveal to everyone how Jamie
pushed him over the tower bran reveals
you might be able to help us in this
fight find that the mud you first bran
has been known to get glimpses of the
future like in season 1 when he has a
dream that predicts his father's death
or in season 6 after he became the
three-eyed Raven he sees the explosion
of the Sept of Baelor before Cersei even
sets her plan in motion but the extent
of these visions aren't entirely known
after all the last three eyed Raven died
or he could fully prepare brand to use
his abilities but if bran can see
glimpses of the future
he obviously has seen something about
Jamie that his role in the war against
the undead will be monumental but to
what extent we'll just have to wait and
see
now I know I said that this was going to
be the last thing I talked about but
just one more tiny thing
the Valyrian word for Lord and light are
axial and Ono's respectively but look at
what the Valyrian words for gold and
hand are XE on and on DOS leading some
to believe the red priest simply
mistranslated the prophecy and the
person they should have been looking for
all along is a savior with a gold hand
so thanks for watching this video please
be sure to LIKE subscribe and share and
I want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below is Jaime azor Ahai or is
there a case for someone better let me
know I've also come out with my latest
episode to breakdown so be sure to check
that out as well until next time
remember daddy loves you very much